[MUSIC PLAYING]
Writing fast and
battery-friendly phone apps
is essential for
making users happy.
But for Android Wear,
it's absolutely critical.
My name's Wayne
Piekarski, and today I'm
going to show you
some simple tricks
to make your Android Wear
apps more battery-efficient.
As we've discussed in earlier
videos such as this DevByte
here, the Data Layer
API provides a mechanism
for Android Wear devices to
communicate with a companion
phone or tablet.
The API provides data items,
which implement data storage,
and automatic
synchronization, and messages
which implement a faster
but not guaranteed
way of sending messages
to another device.
The first thing to realize
when designing your application
architecture is that
your phone typically
has a much more powerful
processor and a much larger
battery than your wearable.
So the best practice
is that you want
to offload as much as possible
away from the wearable
to try to get the most
battery life out of it.
Another key part of the
application architecture
is that the phone has direct
access to the internet,
while the wearable does not.
Imagine a scenario where
you're building an app
to show weather
updates on a wearable.
The phone will need to make
the request to fetch the data
and then send that to the
wearable via the Data Layer
API.
There are many ways
you can implement this,
but if you do not
design this carefully,
it could perform poorly.
So how do we go
about implementing
an efficient solution to this?
One of the first
improvements comes
from changing how you wake
up the wearable device.
Rather than having the wearable
wake up every 10 seconds or so
and request an update from
information from the phone,
instead, you should
allow the phone
to drive updates to
the wearable device.
This simple action of
keeping the watch asleep
as long as possible will help
to conserve battery life.
When implementing
the phone side,
you need to do network requests
for a weather update every so
often.
You should consider using the
JobScheduler API for polling
at a fixed interval
instead of trying
to write your own mechanism.
The JobScheduler is able
to combine your work
with other work that needs
to be done at the same time,
so the CPU can be working
out more efficiently
and saving power on the phone.
Once you've made the weather
update request from the phone,
you may get back
updated information.
An important step to do
here is to compare this
with the previous information
downloaded earlier.
If there's no change
to the information,
you should not update the watch.
There's no point in
waking it up just
to tell it that
nothing has happened.
If you've detected
a change, it's
important to minimize the
amount of data we actually
send to the wearable.
It would be a bad idea to
send the entire weather query
result here to the wearable
since it probably includes
a lot of extra information.
Instead, we should
posit on the phone
and send just a
single temperature
value, in this case.
Remember, we're trying to
minimize the amount of work
done on the wearable.
Even things which might seem
trivial will add up eventually.
So when sending the
data to the wearable,
how should we do that?
If you have to send a large
amount of temperature data
for a time range, it might
be tempting to create
separate data items for
each time and temperature,
and then send them separately.
However, for each
piece of data sent
between the phone
and the wearable,
there are overheads added by
the platform and the network.
These overheads include
headers for packets,
acknowledgements per
packet, and energy required
for every packet sent,
as well as activating
the wireless hardware.
When designing code to
send data over a network,
taking these overheads
into consideration
is very important.
So by storing many numeric
values into a single message,
there will be much less
data sent and processed
than sending each
one separately.
So as you can see
here, the results
can be quite considerable.
Once you've sent the
data to the wearable,
you might be tempted to
add an acknowledgement
to check it was received.
However, if you're
using data items,
they're already guaranteed
by the framework
to be synchronized when
the wearable is paired up.
So you could be sure they'll
eventually be received,
and there's no need for any
further acknowledgement.
However, if you're
using messages,
you might still need
to check they're
received since transmission
is not guaranteed when
the device is disconnected.
So we've walked through
an example of how
to improve performance and
battery life on Android Wear,
and here's a summary
of the key points.
Only request
network updates when
you're certain there
might be a change.
Process the received
data on the phone
to minimize content sent
to the Android Wear device.
Only send updates
to the wearable when
things have actually changed.
Combine multiple
pieces of data together
into single items to
minimize protocol overheads.
And finally, put as much
code on the phone side
as you can since the
watch should only
be used for information
presentation and simple user
interaction.
So these are some simple
but highly effective
ways of writing efficient
applications for Android Wear.
However, there are lots
of other techniques
you can use to improve
your applications as well.
So check out the rest of the
Android Performance Pattern
series to learn more,
because much of it
applies to Android Wear as well.
And don't forget to join us
on the Android Wear Google+
community for tips and
advice from other developers.
So thanks for watching.
I'm Wayne Piekarski, and
keep calm, profile your code,
and always remember,
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]